this capsule we will see how we
evaluates the quality of language models
then one of the ways to evaluate the
quality of language models of a model n
g
it may be going to see if he
allows us better or worse
solve a given problem in a
specific application
we will start by discussing in fact
what kind of application can we
use it and benefit from a model of
the year a first application is
identifying the language of a
given document so imagine that you are
provides to the documents then that the
software in question is identified in
which language was written the document
which is a document in English or in
French located for example for
determine if a corrector
automatic spelling in this look
spelling what language
the heroes should be corrected then
there close to do the identification of
the language is often based on a
language model it works very well
here is the close one begins by defining
a common vocabulary that is common
for all languages ​​so we see
vocabulary v that contains words
common in all languages
wants to identify and then sand
for each language the language it
we want to detect what we are going
to do is to collect a corpus
of documents for that language so
we will find several documents
we know they wrote in the language
and give it to those of his going to define
a priori policy for this language
there if documents that have languages
while we think we are more common
more frequent we can decided
to assign by higher a priori
for these is English otherwise if we
does not want biased a priori the detection
one language more than another
can simply assign a probability
uniform then there a productible each
languages ​​is a finally so for
each of the languages
we want to learn a model ng on the
corpus collected for the language
give is so an ingram model that
had just finished the pole td
observe a word
the position being given hatreds -
a previous word and if I guess that
these words belong to the language
m so that once I did that
well I could actually do for
a new document is to identify
what is the most likely language
most likely
so what is the language she who has the
higher policy given the
words of the document in question
so I want to make a max on l2
so find the language that is the
highest priority politeness and as
in document qualifications b I can
to see that that's equal to the log
of the temporary max of the log of the range
attached looser and the documents so that
it's because I have an alpha constant
that I can eliminate so I can
only consider joined probity
of language and document then I can
take the log of this quality there because
that the log is a transformation
monotonous growth and this hammock this has
actually does I can write it as
the tarmac of the log of probity if the
probability here it's actually the
probability of the language times the
priorities of each of the words knowing the
previous words for assuming that's
belongs to the hike
so if I make the look of this product there
it gives me the log of the scope of the
language plus sum for all the evils
of the log of the priority of these words there
knowing the previous words and as in
qualifications document made
evaluation of all this rag
probability there for different
easy languages ​​and I take the language
that the highest parity and so we
can see that the system like that to
priori I have some good for
some languages ​​or if I wore a
form but all languages
the same value for the log of probity
of the language and then if not I will I
I was just looking at the sum of
the loc pro liter of each of the words in
this language there given the others
words in the document so we can
imagine that for a language or a word
exist
not in that language
priority is going to be very low so the
chances that it is the language that is the
highest part will not be
when I'm going to have more normally
higher and higher specific level
in languages
the easier it will be to distinguish
between different languages ​​with my
model of the year
in fact I could generally
to classify documents
which may be more powerful so
in fact the identification of the language
it's a bit like declassifying
Documents
I have an entry document and then I
wants to determine its category where the
category would be the language so did
what we saw was the equivalent of a
model it's a bit similar actually
business models
when cine + 9 in the sense that I could
a unique model raemdonck gp a model
which assumes that words are
independent of each other
SAC the category so knowing the
language and there are other tasks or
declassification of documents where that's
can be something important to
do a task one can benefit from
take into account their demo it's between
others a task we wish to determine
given the documents that
correspond to comments from
movie reviews if the criticism is
good or not or is good or not how
so is because if their demo is
important indeed the knowledge that the
mob we are present in a review this
can help except that if the word not before
good it changes drastically
the interpretation of the criticism know
if it is positive or negative
so this ca pratean case where a 2nd model
g with one or with n
bigger than one so where am I going
consider more than at least one word
before the word data to evaluate the
word probabilities so the priority
of the document after a hit it can be
useful
and if not no more
applications like the actuation reaction
of text imagine that I write this m deac
seems maybe I would like to
automatic prostitute for simply
add the actions for me so
stormy here would be accented accent
serious
and then the here would be his reaction killed
with a sharp accent so that's
something that can be done with a
model in ga alone
to give you a quick idea threat
what we are looking for in this case is
take a document where the words have not
been accentuated and then turn it into
the document where accents were added
and when you try to do that
find the accented document that most
likely so they look more like
to real documents that have been observed
in our corpus so there are some
techniques to try to do this
difference there the same way in
automatic translation if I produce a
translation I would like my translation
in for example if I translate from
French to English
I would like my translation in
in fact you look like a sentence
normal so this is a sentence that is
likely according to a good model of
language and so in this case we're going
want to integrate that into our system
of translation so that actually between
produces translations that from 1 be
a tradition that could generate the phrase
original and which in addition is a sentence
that could have been observed or to be
said or written by someone so a
sentence that is likely according to our
model of the man so that's why
we will want to introduce models
language in production models
then the same way in recognition of
speech we will see produce
interpret sentences who then want
favor sentences that actually are
sentences that could have been written
in this language the water in whatever
something that could have been said by a
nobody is that it can be evaluated by
a basic model so we were talking to
any early evaluation of models of
language commented what I wanted him
specifically comment on what I
distinguish or that I find the good
hate values ​​of a gram or the
constant rate smoothing or our
constant arrests the ring
constant of interpretation the soul of y
so in fact so constant right we
must be determined before
even to enter us to learn our
model these are the constants that we
calls hypers parameters which so
cdi by m because unlike
probabilities of our model of sound
departure m
these parts and the sound are learned to
from data while end delta
and landry joy the data first
first of all a priori even before
to be able to train the model these are
hypers and to be able to choose in
different language models with
different hate dollars delteil a
website must define some
performance concept then try to
find maybe with research
local for example what is it
n2 values ​​of elton landry who
works best so what are we going
to do typically is that we're actually going
take permission all our data
collected we will put some
side part that will be called who will
which will correspond to our corpus of
validation so what's important here
it's that the validation corpus is going
be recounted the documents that are
other than the documents in our
driving corpora and the notion of a
test corpus that stops did the
corpus convened to evaluate the
final solution for the locks a notion
that against being no more here but I
invite you to see the capsules on
machine learning for con
to make a distinction the most
explicit between notions
validation and test drive
when also in fact all that is to
to know that we have a corpus of
validation which are documents that do not
are not the same as those who are
find in my whole
drive stasi the whole the
drive corpus that was used
to calculate the frequencies of and g
so once we've done that it's actually
the best way true evil to devalue
our language model who to choose
the hand value of a website is
to see what's the performance of
our system on our corpus of
validation if I have a language model
who was trained for some
value n and delta where the employee so for
get me put on my set
drive so that's really the
best way to try
to ultimately optimize the success rate
our system in our application
given on our validation center
so as part of a system
of language identification because
I will do it is that I will have plenty of
documents of different
I want to separate them into a corpus
practice that a corpus of
validation and I will choose the value
of visitors by turitan motherhood who
such as if I train a model
of tongue with this hate pain
their delivery to the parameters
I have the best success rate
identification of the right language for
the documents that is in my
validation set like this is a
example for machine translation
we would do the same thing we would have a
evaluation performance on the corpus
validation that would be otherwise
other documents to translate than those
which are in my whole in
the training corpus but if not so
we do not have an application already defined
and if in fact we
so we might be interested
have a performance measure that is
a bit independent of an application
since language models actually
could be used in different
applications
what we're going to do is we're going
use what is called perplexity
it's a formula that seems a little
complicated but in the lead all that
finds to be it's perplexity so
for a given document it's going to be the
probability of this document there at least
sure d ok so we can see that in fact
as a kind of probabilities but
standardized by normalized by length
of the document so our way of writing it
in fact it's that exponential one of
the sum of the locality of all evils
in the previous alignment but
standardized by dividing by by and after
I take the average -7 exponential
localities of words that's another
way to see it is like
the exponential of less
the log likelihood of words
and averages / so the justification of
behind that and is inspiring rode the
information theory it's some
something that I will not deal with here but that
to know essentially is that plus one
angle model associates
probabilities that they are elevated to
documents that are real documents
data extracts and then the most the
perplexity vote to be actually beats
more big enough if I take at least
one on mets plus all this term there is going
may be small so what we
would like in this case arrested tiki
the lowest possible and surmounted corpus
of validation choose is actually the
model in g or a language model that
would have the lowest perplexity for
all the validation corpus so for
where there is that probability in
made of all the documents in my
validation set and finally a
way maybe a little bit more
intuitive or in any case more fun
evaluate the quality of models and g
these two squarely sampled or
generate documents from our
model took so somehow
what we are going to do is let's leave
the machine speak German or the
machine correspondence it's a
other year model so what I
will do is that I and champion ray the
first word w1 then from his part of w
a game to sample the second
word w2 from May 1st w1 that I have
champion is wise and the championships
from my probity w2 given
w12 would be the priority of w3 sacha w 1
and w2a champion raymond third
like that then can model trigram
there I will continue like that where I
champion raymond fourth word of the
policy was raining cap and gave w2 and
w3 so only the two months
previous ones and I will continue like that
to generate text asked for
language
the example just gave this model
trigram because I condition
only or more on my last three
month
the last two montages and we have
examples here from the reference book
is actually what they did it's
that they resulted in a unique pattern
rambi g or sort g on the text content
in the leading reference book and
so what is observed for a model
unique, in fact, we observe
documents or word order has
absolutely no sense logical orascom
youngest 28 is because a model
united g
the probability of a word our departure in
previous demo mode a bit like in a
model the business model multi the
viable short of models 10 grams the
it will condition on the previous word
and there we get documents from
sentences that have little more than 100 systems
are very rare mistakes confided tajine
to reproaches rugby represents so we
here sees that a little uncertain unplanned
in the syntax but still some of the
phrases that took
individually to ten years and then more
we increase the value of m so his pass
surpassed n is equal to 3 but here we have
way ends a little longer longer
of planning and sending offers
embedded in some semantic countries
or seven x axes of success of the world
so we see that the tips of
sentences that are coherent themselves are
a little longer although the sentence to
racial conflicts this will not be entirely
coherent and the more we increase n is no longer
we gave but in our model
pathak so that's another way
to have an idea of ​​the quality of our
model gr